Grant has recruited Athena, with all of her experience designing things, to
create a new logo for the Gleaming Glasses company. It's going to have a pair
of glasses on it, of course, and Athena wants to make sure that the glasses are
exactly symmetric. Now, she really likes the look of the function f of x equals
x to the 4th, what I have graphed right here. So, she's trying to figure out
how to use it to make the glasses. We need to figure out how to help Athena
transform this function. Flip it over, move it from side to side, like this,
and also move it up and move it down. All these different kinds of
transformations are definitely going to be required for the design of this
logo. Let's help her out.